Marjorie Taylor green during yesterday's
failed humiliating instantly imploding
Twitter hearings wrongly claimed that
Twitter broke the law when they
suspended her account because she
violated their terms of service she
doesn't understand the law or the First
Amendment but her followers don't either
so this stuff is really effective listen
to her rant let's explain
52 United States law
10101 no person shall intimidate
threaten coerce or attempt to stop any
other I've never heard the word coerce
pronounced coerce she really speaks in
an interesting way a person for the
purpose of interfering with their rights
to vote or to vote as he may choose you
didn't Shadow ban or permanently ban my
Democrat opponent because your Democrat
opponent didn't violate Twitter's terms
of service
no you did that to me
and that was wrong and it was against
the law it was against the law wait no
it wasn't
you see not only that was it was it me
that you violated my first amendment
rights you violated countless
conservative Americans these were
doctors that were trying to tell the
truth about coven doctor they were
liners that were having success treating
people with Ivermectin that is not a
scientifically demonstrated claim and in
fact Ivermectin does not work on covet
that you all would not allow to be
talked about on your platform these were
parents complaining about their school
boards teaching gender lives in their
schools biological males entering their
daughter's bathrooms and sports
these were also people questioning the
2020 election and guess what that's
Americans First Amendment right notice
how on that one she doesn't say they
were right to question it she's now
moved to they are allowed to question it
under the First Amendment Now understand
that Marjorie Taylor green has no clue
and no understanding of the First
Amendment nor of the law so I know many
of you know this but let's put it
together nice and concisely here as far
as the first amendment goes it applies
to the government it does not apply to
private companies like Twitter so when
Twitter decides to ban someone it is not
a violation of their constitutional
rights could Twitter commit a crime by
Banning people sure if Twitter was
Banning people
either overtly or it could be
demonstrating demonstrated that they
were targeting people of certain
protected classes for Banning if Twitter
all of a sudden was Banning Jews from
Twitter for being Jewish or Banning
black people from Twitter because they
were black that would be a crime it
wouldn't be a First Amendment issue it
would be a non-discrimination issue but
the First Amendment does not apply to
Twitter now then you get to the second
part of the argument which is that some
people argue that because Twitter is
such a big platform it should be treated
as a public forum now that is not the
law that is not the law it is not the
law but let's imagine for the sake of
argument that we accept that that's the
way it should be
the First Amendment also doesn't
guarantee the right to speech in all
circumstances nor does it guarantee
freedom from consequences of your speech
there are still limits on speech
incitement to violence or whatever the
case may be it is circumstantial but
that's if we imagine that the law is
different than it is and Marjorie Taylor
green said this was a First Amendment
violation and it was a crime
even if someone's speech isn't ex
prohibited social media platforms still
have the right to set their own
standards and enforce them as they see
fit I've been the Target or I guess I
could say the victim of the
misenforcement of these policies when
YouTube was it YouTube No when Instagram
had a policy against coveted
disinformation I did a video
covering a guy who said drink urine for
covid okay I didn't say drink urine for
covet I would never do that I wouldn't
suggest distilling urine drinking it
injecting it using it uh for flambe I
would not suggest urine for covet in any
way
however I was caught up
and we had a problem because the terms
of service were misapplied because I
quoted someone spreading covet
disinformation I was caught up in it it
wasn't a crime I disagreed with that
because it was not an application fairly
of the terms of service but none of it
relates to criminality
but with them everything's always a
crime now one other argument that
Republicans sometimes make is that
social media censorship is biased
against conservatives the reality is
social media companies are private
businesses they can enforce their
policies however they want if they
wanted to ban conservatives they would
be allowed to do that now again it goes
back to well Twitter so big it should be
regulated in a different way should be
and is are two completely different
things and lastly remember that these
social media platforms aren't the only
way to communicate with others to
express themselves so one of the
arguments people like Marjorie Taylor
green are making are have been
when I am running a campaign against
someone else I'm speaking as a Marjorie
now I know it's hard to imagine but I'm
speaking as Marjorie she argues when I'm
running a campaign against someone else
and you ban me and not them essentially
it's almost like a campaign contribution
of sorts it's against the law you're
silencing me first amendment oh we've
debunked basically every aspect of that
but the other thing you have to remember
is Twitter is not the only way that you
run a campaign Twitter is not a
requirement to run campaigns there's TV
she can put her videos up on on YouTube
Facebook all these different things she
can be interviewed Etc
so also in that way it is neither a
crime nor a violation of anyone's rights
absolute last thing on this there's also
the business regulation hypocrisy of
these people when they make these claims
on the one hand Republicans claim to be
against government intervention and
business and at the same time here they
are demanding Twitter should be forced
to publish someone's tweets why that's
extremely heavy-handed regulation to
come in and say to a private business we
as the government are going to tell you
you've got to publish urine conspiracies
you've got to publish marjories
conspiracies or whatever the case may be
so this is absurd in every way Marjorie
Taylor green is wrong on every one of
these claims but you go to a trump rally
and you interview people and they go oh
Twitter's violating People's First
Amendment rights because they don't know
any better all of these clips will be on
our YouTube channel youtube.com slash
the David Pacman show one of our
sponsors is Helix sleep I have been
sleeping on a helix mattress at home for
years now I couldn't be more happy with
it I recommend it to everybody the other
day even though she's not allowed in the
big bed I put my baby daughter on the
mattress and even she loved it Helix
sleep is the premium mattress brand
offering tailored mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences take the
Helix sleep quiz it asks you about your
body type your sleeping position do you
get hot at night do you have back pain
and then Helix will match you with the
mattress that's perfect for you most
people don't know where to begin when
shopping for a mattress including me
Helix makes it simple and less risky
because you know you're getting a
mattress that fits your needs it ships
free you can try it for a hundred nights
to see if you like it and it comes with
a 10 or 15 year warranty unlike many
mattress companies all Helix mattresses
are made in the USA by a skilled
production team so you are supporting
good jobs helix sleep is giving my
audience up to twenty percent off plus
two free pillows what other mattress
company is going to give you twenty
percent off go to helixsleep.com Pacman
the link is down below